hi I'm Zack wife's Miller for recent TV
we're in Tampa Florida
reporting from day one of the 2012
Republican National Convention the
Chairman is about to call the convention
into order and then unveil a debt clock
that will be posted the entire time
we're going to ask participants whether
the national debt is an important issue
and whether Mitt Romney is the person to
tackle that issue for this convention we
also want to draw your attention to the
unprecedented fiscal recklessness of the
Obama administration as depicted by the
real-time National Debt Clock shown here
in the arena there's a national debt
clock clicking away up there is the
national debt an important issue to you
I think it definitely is and really to
all young Americans I hope to to be an
ambassador really for all Americans what
kind of programs would you like to see
cut in order to get that started that's
a difficult liberal question you cut
them all what are some of the ones that
come to the top of your head for
instance I mean just you look at every
regulation that's been passed in the
last four or five years now you've got
so much waste I mean you look at that
Solyndra high-speed rail some of our
social welfare programs the big three
drivers of debt are Medicare Social
Security and Defense should those also
be on the chopping block what do you say
chopping block we have to reform those
so we don't go in debt but obviously we
want those programs around when you get
to be of age Medicare Social Security
and defense spending
do those need to be on the table also
the thing is Obama's cut Medicare by
quite a bit in the past Republicans
haven't exactly been that much better I
mean Bush racked up over four trillion
dollars in debt during his term do you
think Romney and Ryan are gonna be
different
I think a lot of people are excited cuz
he has that he put Ryan on the ticket
with the Ryan plan even the Ryan plan
which is not the same as the Romney plan
doesn't actually balance the budget for
about 30 years is that good enough well
it's a start it's better I mean we have
a president who for four years hasn't
even done a budget defense that's
increased seventy percent since george w
bush
office should we roll it back to before
that time I don't think 70 percents a
correct number but if we don't have a
strong military we're not going to be
able to ensure peace in the world after
9/11 everybody remembers 9/11 but nobody
talks about it the costs of Defense to
keep the United States and its people
secure within its borders went up
drastically we understand that and as
somebody that has worn the uniform I
applaud that sort of movement by our
government overseas military bases or
our presence in Afghanistan does any of
that need to be rethought by the
Republican Party well you know I think
for no I don't think we should just pull
out of Afghanistan I would take a lot of
the troops that are in a lot of these
countries like Japan and Germany and I
bring them back to this country but
that's my personal opinion
right that's not something that Romney's
been a I'm not sure of his position on
that